cela faisait des mois qu'elle y penser
au sein de la caq de françois legault
elle dit n'avoir jamais été heureux je
pense que la guerre fois jamais
fonctionné qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire jamais senti que j'avais mon espace
en coach ça ne jamais cliquer ce que je
pense
sylvie roy a été élu cinq fois à
l'action démocratique du québec en 2003
d'abord et lorsque la caq avaler là dès
qu elle a toujours été réélu sans
difficulté la dea qui ce dit que le chef
caquistes ne lui a jamais donné la place
qui lui revenait
j'appelle pas ça gonfle personnalités
telles simple tout caractère
incompatibles on n'avait pas de chicane
on se parle pas trop mais elle ajoute
qu'elle n'était pas écouté la
politicienne souhaité faire plus
d'interventions dans les
circonscriptions
je suis une femme de terrain dit elle
alors que le chef legault privilégier le
travail au parlement
j'ai une autre vision que quelqu'un qui
a toujours vécu comme ça
l'avocate de 50 ans est une politicienne
aguerrie qui s'est fait connaître pour
avoir talonné le gouvernement charest
dans le scandale de la collusion qui
minent l industrie de la construction
qu'ils appellent une commission d'
enquête publique
c'est la première à avoir réclamé une
commission denquête public son départ
s'ajoute aux démissions de plusieurs
députés vedette jacques duchesneau
christian dubé et gérard deltell au
parti on affirme que le cas de sylvie
roy est différent qu'elle a des
problèmes personnels d'un problème des
absences des échos dans sa
circonscription mois comme comme il eut
comme collègues comme ami je me suis
déplacée j'ai passé l'après-midi
humainement j'ai tout fait il ajoute que
le parti a tout fait pour les aider
martin la caté vote donc des problèmes
de comportement vous y croyez peut-être
céline mais des problèmes de
comportement il y en a dans tous les
caucus et c'est le défi du chef de tenir
son caucus autour de lui bien ensemble
il faut qu'ils rendent chaque député
heureux est occupée qui étend dorloter
certains plus que d'autres
alors est ce que sylvie roy avait ses
défauts peut-être mais il ne faut pas
regarder bien bien loin pour trouver
d'autres cas au printemps françois
legault qui commentait le départ de
gérard deltell a laissé entendre qu'il
avait des problèmes de relations au sein
du caucus
bon ça fait quand même beaucoup de
départs au sein de la cac et pas
seulement chez les députés martine oui
voilà un calcul survol de mes notes
montre que depuis trois ans il y a eu
près de 13 des parts alors on essaie sur
les vedettes mais il ya eu des départs
des membres du conseil exécutif des
attachés de presse des attachés
politiques
le dernier en lice jean luc benoît la
semaine dernière le directeur des
communications un ancien adéquiste n'a
pas fait un an
alors est-ce que la cac est à la croisée
des chemins
peut-être que françois legault devra se
payer le luxe d'un examen conscience
merci beaucoup merci au revoir